the Nostalgia Critic is missing presumed
fucking terrified however he did leave
one extra video for you this week hello
I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy remember it
so you don't have to and welcome to
another installment of what you never
know this is where we look back at those
movies you've seen a million times but
still managed to miss one or two little
details with that said let's take a look
at Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles no not
that shit I'm talking about the real
Ninja Turtles call the real Ninja
Turtles guys are really fucking down the
original cinematic best-looking Ninja
Turtles from the 90s and not when they
look like Sesame Street or ran their
faces into a wall we all love this corny
nonsense from our past but how much do
we really know about what was going on
in plain sight that you never noticed
before they're not behind the scenes
facts or nitpicking plat holes they're
just the kick-ass little moments you
never realize we're making the movie
even more tickets let's not waste any
time let's take a look at the original
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles movie
we all know april o'neil before running
joke all the other reporters are named
after months of the year as well April
O'Neill exactly June May Williams over
at channel 5 April May and June hey if
giant surfing Turtles can be named after
Renaissance painters anything flies it
was a joke if you look closely in the
foots warehouse you'll notice that
there's a box for Archie comics the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles adventures
at the time were also being produced by
Archie comics - I do hope there's more
them in another life listen closely to
where this kid says the foot clans
hideout ends we check out the East
warehouse over the admin Island that's
East warehouse on Laird Min Island a nod
to Eastman and Laird who are the
original creators of the Ninja Turtles
comic that started at all good in joke
there kid I hope you go places this kid
went places he Sam Rockwell in the
original comic the turtles all looked
and acted identically even down to
wearing the same colored Mass when the
cartoon came out they gave them
different personalities and different
colored maths however if you were to see
them in black and white you still
wouldn't be able to tell them apart
that's why in the film they all have
unique facial and body structures
Leonardo for example is the thinnest
tallest and most even balanced
Michelangelo is the most wide-eyed and
expressive Raphael is the most brutal
it--with stronger muscles and a
permanent sneer and down the tail always
what's the most inquisitive with his
faced often in pondering mode every one
of these changes for flex the
personality that was given to them more
dishes to wardrobe would carry over in
the 2014 film as well but like I said
wall to face syndrome come on guys with
a bigger nose at Judea where did it come
up with this stuff
all the actors inside the Turtle suits
also made appearances outside of the
turtle suits
remember that pizza guy that's
Michelangelo the foot so that you're
talking to April that's Donatello one of
the gang members here that's Leonardo
and remember that passenger watching
Raphael flipped over the cab
that's Raphael himself and as an added
bonus Kino in the second digit Toros
film was actually the stunt double for
Donatello hey anyone who can work in
those suits deserves their own part of
the movie does everybody does the voice
of splinter sound familiar to you you
are still young but one day I will be
gone right he sounds exactly like L okay
I don't care if you can't hear it but it
is the same guy Kevin Clash both the
puppeteer and voice for Elmo did the
exact same thing for splinter not only
providing the voice but also being one
of the many puppeteers to operate it hey
as long as Elmo's vocals don't come out
of his lips I'm good people growing up
with the turtles today know all the
characteristics right Leo is the leader
Donnie's the brains Mikey's the goof-off
and rats the loner but actually in the
cartoon both Raph and Mikey were the
goof-offs the main difference being Raph
was a bit more cynical and quick-witted
where Mikey was a bit more of a
light-hearted doofus when the movie came
along they decided both of them were a
little too similar
so they made Raphael and angry and
impulse a tough guy who often liked to
do things on his own where Michelangelo
would handle more of a goofy humor this
would stick with them in future
variations including cartoons and movies
will you act like a jerk sometimes you
know that remember the song turtle power
the song that played during the end
credits of the movie
I guess the rap group partners in crime
must have been real fans of the turtles
huh bullshit if you listen to the song
you'll hear clearly that they get the
wrong turtle who's the leader
Michelangelo and make up the team
without oh you fuck backers Leonardo
this resulted in so many playground
battles did they get it wrong it's Raph
the new leader now was he always the
leader
did we just misinterpret things this
debate literally resulted in minutes
minutes of intense arguing among second
graders everywhere and our throats are
still sore I hope your next project
search as punishment for such a
horrendous mistake good actually how
does ice always kill everything
associated with turtles who the hell is
that guy huh weird a lot of people take
the scene where Michelangelo ignores
Donatello as him not listening or caring
about what he has to say with splinter
hey Mikey
did you ever think about what splinter
said tonight I mean about what it would
be like yet no not having them
time's up three bucks off but there is
another way to look at this you will
notice later how Michelangelo is the one
crying the hardest when they communicate
with their lost master it's totally
possible that instead of ignoring
Donatello he could just be in denial
like the idea of him being gone is so
painful he'd rather not think about at
all maybe I mean too deep into it but
you never know who forgot kids while
many people think the movie is adapted
from only the cartoon it's actually a
mix of both the cartoon and the original
comic most of us know the contributions
from the show but the backstory is more
like the comic the show's design is more
like the comic the lack of robotic Foot
Clan is more like the comic the climax
on top of the building is more like the
comic even the slightly darker tone and
heavier shadows seem to be more like the
comic this came at just the right time
as Batman was released a year earlier
and show that a grittier take on comic
books was totally doable we all are Jim
well mostly Krieger and I thought
everybody loves man-up oh my god did
Donatelli eat somebody actually that's
the puppeteers mouth showing through it
happens a few times in the film in fact
there's a few moments where you can see
the wires wear and tear and like I said
before the puppeteers exactly what point
did we lose control here
in honor of the recent passing of Robin
Williams I present a surprisingly small
contribution that he made to the first
Turtles bill you see he was filming a
movie called Cadillac man which he
co-starred in with well Judith Hoag who
you and later know as a bro Neil being a
big fan of the cartoon and comic he was
giving her advice and information about
O'Neill's character information she said
later was very helpful nothing major but
it's good to know he was still
influencing our childhoods one way or
another awesome and the number one thing
you never knew about Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles is nobody wanted to make
it weird right while the most product
producing merchandise selling cash cows
of the 80s and 90s and the film based on
it nobody had any interest in all the
major studios turned it down as a result
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles is actually
an independent movie yup no studio
bought it until months into filming when
then newcomer New Line Cinema purchased
it as a result your childhood icons
became the highest grossing independent
movie of all time
that is until Blair Witch Project came
out nine years later but hey I'll take
turtle power over seeing nothing anytime
of the day there any more than you
noticed are there any more little
touches we're talking about we'll leave
them in the comments below and keep
talking about a movie that's definitely
worth talking about I'm the Nostalgia
Critic I remember so you don't have to
you